What does a country still synonymous
with football do to get its yellow color
away from right wing politics?
I'm talking about Brazil, where the
recent election was a close call.
And Lula was just a little over 50
percent of the vote.
Now there is a similar division over the
country's iconic yellow jersey.
It's both a symbol of the country's
dominance over the sports, and it's also
worn by the supporters of right wing
outgoing president.
False scenario.
They wear it to rallies and they wear it
to protest the new leftwing president
elect.
Ahead of this year's World Cup, Brazil's
football association is trying to wash
politics from the famous shirt.
He wants to be a campaign and in it, a
rap song.
Players over cheering, fans all dressed
in yellow.
The lyrics of which translate to Let's
love her and let's go yellow.
Many are skeptical, though they can
bridge the divide over the color.
Sports pundits tell me the use of
Brazil's national colors dates back to
Brazil's military dictatorship, which
ended in 1985 under Boston, although the
embrace of yellow jersey was taken to a
new level.
So many fans don't want to wear any more
street hawkers in Rio de Janeiro or even
tell me they're selling more blue shirts
these days.